this week in social justice warrior
leftism a few crazy stories I want to
start with one that the left believes to
be reasonable and then another one that
some of the left to believe to be
unreasonable
I think either you're all-in or you're
not all-in so here's a clip that went
online I think it was at BuzzFeed
everyone was talking about how beautiful
it is
it's a feminist who was married to a man
telling her daughter that her husband
the girl's daddy is now a woman and
you're supposed to feel good about this
let's roll the clip
yeah what how does that make you feel
good it does make you feel good yeah you
want to be like a boy you go well I
actually really feel happy as a girl and
I'm gonna stay like a girl no that's
nice but daddy doesn't feel happy as a
boy so we have decided to help daddy
become the person that his brain and his
heart tell him that he really is so
instead of yes exactly
no not again so when mommy and daddy
went on that date on Saturday we went
and got some new clothes and we got like
all new girl clothes and we got daddy
some makeup okay I want to get them yeah
and now daddy's gonna wear some makeup
his white girl's clothes and grow maybe
grow daddy's hair out so we get this
girl's face she doesn't know it are you
okay with it yeah you know that daddy's
still gonna be the same person no he's
gonna be your daddy daddy's still going
to be mentally ill do you know that how
do you think of daddy's new name you
like it yeah this girl knows the camera
yeah look at the camera and tell daddy
malory what you think is happening it
feels
can you tell him not to tell her how
much you love her daddy the most basic
that's just this is the worst first off
people think you know you build up
Easter this is literally the blue hair -
pierced spacers and the ear feminists we
make fun of it's borderline child abuse
first if I hate the gimmick of using
children and I love what I do love about
this and this is something that people
miss is the response from the child
directly correlates to the emotional
maturity of the father and a mother
daddy feels like a girl
ha how do you feel about that I feel
good well now you're making life
decisions with the exact same moral
compasses daddy that's all that's
required it feels good yeah what do you
feel about rape depends how it feels
this is so far off the beam at this
point and people want people are well
they want to act as those as beautiful
if you speak out against it this is hate
speech of course and then his other
story occurred at Daily Mail and they
don't know how they feel about this let
me set this up for you
this is someone who calls themselves
dragon lady Tomic Medusa from Maricopa
County Arizona has removed his ears and
nose and had surgical procedures to
become a dragon born a man too so also a
[ __ ] but a dragon [ __ ] dragon dragon
tails okay let's bring this clip up
well Zeid and too many people who got to
know me from years ago i am also known
as known anpan and no man pan is my
prior
no one knows or that you mentioned about
my metamorphosis project just quickly
I'm a metamorphosis project is it's
basically my transitioning from the no
man pen man that I was to the Eva that I
am NOT today I am a father a great
teenage kid I'm he's a sophomore in high
school
so you watch this and you go that's
absurd right
someone's trying to turn themselves into
a mythical figure that's impossible
you know what else is impossible a man
turning himself into a woman it's not
scientifically it's not physically
possible to do nobody has a sex change
operation that works your body tries to
fix it as a wound it's a very hard
moment they toss on a dress and we all
have to act like they're a girl
otherwise it's a speech so I was sitting
there and I forced me to do some
soul-searching crazy thing is I found
some dragon ladies in my soul so I think
there's I think we need to call a priest
the left is trying to say well it's
perfectly fine for this man to turn into
a woman but going into a dragon we're
not sure if we want to accept that as
normal okay cut off his ears and nose to
become a dragon we have the image
chariot can bring up my screen here you
can see it cut off the ears and nose to
become a dragon this person seems absurd
no more absurd than cutting off your
tallywacker putting some knobs in your
forehead and calling them horns doesn't
seem that big of a deal once you cut off
your penis and create a wound that you
have to repeatedly open otherwise your
body closes it and you're pumping your
body full of hormones that no doubt will
put you in a shallow cancerous quite in
that grave in the name of love however
because we wouldn't want to be
intolerant how do you feel about dragon
lady who the guy who's at oh the dragon
dude nobody wants to be a lady now well
cool the lady part okay
I'm not hateful not sure how I feel
about the dragon part are we sure that's
not possible I think we're quite sure
that's not possible are you sure it's
not possible yes I'm quite confident
that turning a man into a dragon is not
humanly possible this isn't Game of
Thrones I'm also quite confident that
turning a man richard hernandez into a
woman it is not possible by quite
certain I mean 100% the reason I wanted
to include these two together is again
you can't say you can't start off with
men and women are fundamentally
interchangeable which is required for
same sex marriage which is required for
this trans LGBTQA AIP real acronym
movement and then all of a sudden say
well listen we don't know how we feel
about the dragon situation we need to
create dragon bathrooms by the way
you're still here that's surprising I'm
not going to lie this is the Internet
most people have an attention span of
four seconds but this is the clip taken
from the full weekly videocast podcast
you can click below to watch that full
video cast or subscribe on iTunes or
SoundCloud click my face it a lot of ask
writer comm where there are more
articles and you could read in a
lifetime or click below me where there's
another video it's shorter because I
know you're busy and you have things to
do like find pants